are you self-employed freelancing do you
have a side hustle all of these are
various types of independent contracting
that together make up what's become
known as the gig economy three and ten
Americans work a gig job of some kind or
another and for many freelancing is
synonymous with freedom but freedom
isn't free there's a lot of instability
that comes with the gig economy it's a
hustle it's a grind
you don't have that safety net of a
salaried job basically working from
paycheck to paycheck this is good money
and we're here to help you run the
business of you okay so the gig economy
is a broad topic so let's separate it
into two sections
there's the career freelancer and the
side hustler and let's start with side
hustling because I'm a humble video
producer and I could use some extra
scratch but well I get in trouble with
my company for doing that I wish there
was somebody I could talk to about this
hey you gotta say I can help you out
with this who are you my name is Mark
Kohler I'm just sitting over here
reading my own book on the very topic
you're talking about oh yeah sure
will I get in trouble with my company if
I want to start a side hustle generally
not unless you're gonna try to start a
small business in your industry nine
times out of ten you're gonna be fine
you can go out and do whatever you want
once you are a side hustler you're
basically a small business yeah yeah a
lot of people don't realize if I'm just
even driving for uber yeah you're
getting a 1099 baby that's a small
business let's take advantage of it and
the tax write-offs could be phenomenal
yeah sure tell me about this well under
the new tax cuts and Jobs Act or so we
got what's called the 20% pass-through
we've got cell phone home office
computers electronics travel auto all
these little things that you might be
paying for anyway I call personal
conversion expenses so what happens if
my side hustle becomes so successful
that you know it's cutting into all my
time well congratulations
now you've graduated to career
freelancer your full-time business owner
it's better to quit your job now and
make more money at home you know what I
quit wait a second was that a good idea
what about my vacation time my 401 K my
health insurance and that discounted gym
membership I never signed up for
freelancing seems like a lot more work
than a staff job mostly because you have
to do everything yourself I'm gonna need
some more guidance before I call myself
a career freelancer and what better
place to seek advice than the
freelancers Union so let's head to their
HQ and talk to executive director
Katelyn Pierce let's say I just became a
career freelancer what can I do to feel
as secure as I did as a staffer you know
when people are thinking about whether
or not become a freelancer I always say
before you make that leap think about a
couple of things one is you know what is
your plan for earning enough income not
just to support yourself but also to
take on the additional costs of managing
your tax burden paying for your own
health and benefits and having a savings
plan for retirement
should I be hiring somebody to do my
taxes for me short answer yes one of the
things all freelancers need especially
if they're doing this full-time is
someone that can help you understand
what you can deduct for your business
and make sure that you've done your
taxes properly so you
end up with the liability at the end of
the year could you give me a few
financial tips that help freelancers
remain secure first of all every
freelancer needs to have a good contract
that they've worked with a lawyer on
that they understand that's going to
protect their work and make sure they
get paid on time secondly you should
have a system by which you are
automatically setting aside 30 percent
of your income into taxes as soon as it
comes in before you can touch it and if
you can also setting aside income in
short-term and long-term savings the
third thing I think is that you should
really set aside 10% of your time for
long term planning and that should
include business building activities
like client prospecting networking
investing in training or upskilling and
it's really important for you to have a
vision for where you're going think
about where you want to be in five years
financially and professionally and be
making steps towards working towards
those goals so that should get all you
freelancers and side hustlers off on the
right foot
as for me I'm gonna go beg for my cushy
staff job back
you
[Music]
you